shampoing coupe brushing et coloration
tous les services d'un salon de coiffure
traditionnelle
à un détail près ici les tarifs sont
adaptés aux plus démunis de 3 à 8 euros
maximum
un salon de coiffure solidaire pour
retrouver confiance en soi entre les
mains bénévoles de nathalie c'est
important de se regarder dans un miroir
et de ne pas se déclarent ne se dire
tiens aujourd'hui j'ai une bonne mine
j'ai une bonne tête je vais aller vers
les autres parce que je me vois bien
tout à l'heure la dame j'ai fait un
petit massage aller contente parce que
c'est pas des choses qu'on a l'habitude
d'avoir rendre la coiffure et l'estiment
de soit accessible quel que soit son
revenu
c'était le pari de la mairie d'elancourt
installé dans le centre social l'agora
ce nouveau salon a été inauguré le 8
décembre en présence du maire jean
michel fourgous et de son adjointe
martine letoublon à l'initiative du
projet les personnes qui viennent dans
ce salon réunit enfin essentiellement
les personnes qui sont à la recherche
d'un emploi qui ont un entretien
d'embauché parce qu'on est là vraiment
pour leur tendre la main pour les
réinsérer dans la vie professionnelle
il ya aussi les personnes qu'ils soient
handicapés qui ont dit faible revenu les
personnes
on oublie souvent les personnes âgées
qui se retrouve avec le minimum
vieillesse qui ne peuvent pas aller chez
le coiffeur
le salon est ouvert les mercredis matin
sur rendez-vous seules obligations
demandées par nathalie repartir avec le
sourire